PROCEDURES, SENATOR SCOTT ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARINGS
VIRTUALLY.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT HAS REINSTATED A
REQUIREMENT IN SOUTH CAROLINA
THAT ABSENTEE VOTERS PROVIDE A
WITNESS SIGNATURE ALONG WITH
THEIR BALLOT.
HERE WITH REACTION, SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, MITCH McCONNELL IS
CLEAR.
YOU HAVE BEEN CLEAR.
OCTOBER 12, THE HEARINGS BEGIN.
THAT WOULD LEAD US TO A FINAL
VOTE BY THE END OF OCTOBER.
AM I MISTAKEN ON THAT TIMELINE?
>> NO.
I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND WE ARE
GOING TO START THE HEARINGS
OCTOBER 12TH, A WEEK FROM TODAY.
SAFELY.
IF MEMBERS FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON, THEY CAN DO IT
VIRTUALLY.
WE HAVE DONE THAT A BUNCH THIS
YEAR.
ALREADY IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
JUDGE BARRETT WILL BE THERE IN
PERSON.
I WILL BE THERE IN PERSON.
WE WILL SET THE ROOM UP FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON.
AS FOR SENATOR SCHUMER, IF HE IF
CAN SEE THERE’S, YOU’RE NOT
LOOKING VERY HARD.
I DON’T REMEMBER SENATOR SCHUMER
ASKING PROTESTERS TO BE TESTED
BEFORE THEY CAME TO MY HOUSE AND
BROKE OUT MY WINDOW.
I DON’T REMEMBER ANY DEMOCRAT
WORRIED ABOUT TESTING DURING THE
RIOTS.
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO DEFLECT AND
DELAY.
IT WILL NOT WORK.
SHE WILL BE CONFIRMED THIS YEAR.
WE START ON THE 12TH.
SHE GETS REPORTED OUT OF
COMMITTEE ON OCTOBER 22ND.
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE PLENTY OF
TIME TO ASK HER HARD RELEVANT
QUESTIONS.
IF THEY TRY TO DESTROY HER, IT
WILL BLOW UP IN THEIR FACE LIKE
IT DID WITH KAVANAUGH.
I AM EXCITED ABOUT THE HEARINGS
I WANT EVERY AMERICAN TO SEE AMY
BARRETT AND HOW QUALIFIED SHE
IS.
>> Sean: AROUND OCTOBER 26, IS
THAT A SAFE DATE TO LOOK FOR
FINAL VOTE IN THE SENATE ON
THIS?
>> IT IS UP TO
SENATOR McCONNELL BUT IT WILL
BE ON THE FLOOR OCTOBER 22ND.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO DESTROY
HER ALREADY, USING HER RELIGION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS TRYING
TO TAKE BACK THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE, BEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY ARE HAVING AN INSANE AMOUNT
OF MONEY FROM THIS ACTIVE LUCITE
RAISED OVER THREE AND HER
MILLION SINCE JUSTICE GINSBURG
PASS.
MY OPPONENT IN SOUTH CAROLINA
FOR ABOUT ALL PLACES WILL RAISE
$100 MILLION.
IF YOU ARE OUT THERE AND YOU
WANT TO CLOSE THE GAP, GO TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM.COM TO HELP ME
BECAUSE I’M GOING TO BE FIGHTING
FOR JUDGE BARRETT.
I’M GOING TO BE STANDING UP FOR
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES AND I’M
GOING TO HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP
GET THIS NOMINEE THROUGH AND ON
THE COURT.
IT WILL BE A TREMENDOUS
ACKNOWLEDGMENT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OUR COUNTRY
TO HAVE ANY BARRETT ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Sean: I THOUGHT YOU DID